una especie de remake de la jornada
anterior se vivió en esta etapa 18 del
tour de francia aunque eso sí los
niveles de emoción se mantuvieron a tope
el imparable está de spock ayer volvió a
conquistar una etapa es la tercera vez
que lo hace en esta edición de la gira
gana tras transcurrir esos 130
kilómetros que incluyeron el mítico paso
de tu male a más de 2 mil metros de
altitud y por si fuera poco el esloveno
también se coronó como el rey de la
montaña' luciendo otra vez ese mayo
blanco de lunares le siguieron en el
trío de ganadores se subieron también al
podio el danés jonas bin llegará en
segundo lugar y el ecuatoriano richard
cara paz en tercero a estas alturas del
tour de francia todo parece indicar que
la historia de 2020 va a repetirse de
hecho sólo un milagro pudiera impedir
que tales ponga ser se coronen
nuevamente como portador del mayo
amarillo en esta edición del tour de
francia' 2021